we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
will go to our next caller from the 864
area code who's been holding on for a
while caller what's your name and where
are you calling from uh-uh my name is
Raymond from South Carolina or not from
South yo I'm just with it with um but
yeah basically uh I got no politics some
time ago when I first got in it was with
Alex Jones and and that crowded although
I don't follow him anymore I never
really I guess got rid of the conspiracy
theory side and i don't know like lately
with the whole rise of Trump and
everything that's going on and I guess I
had this fear of a purge of the left I
guess you'd say coming and I'm wondering
talking about like anybody else kind of
yeah I like what was exactly like what
Hitler did when I when he first started
it wasn't the juzi it started with it
was I think it was communist and
socialist that he is actually initially
went after and then moved on to other
things and I'm just um I'm kind of
curious and nobody else kind of I guess
seized it the possibility of it or
something or I'll see anyone else
talking about it we'll listen I mean
I've talked about how without saying
that Trump is Hitler that there are
similarities between pre-world War to
Germany and the sort of authoritarian
panaceas that John Donald Trump has been
promising throughout his campaign and
also as president I I am concerned about
many aspects of Trump but I'm personally
not thinking that it's going to velop
develop into a holocaust of the left pad
I mean I don't maybe people aren't
talking about it because it doesn't
actually seem that likely i think we
certainly would be the first people to
be rounded up so if you see that that's
a warning yeah but but beyond that I
don't I'm not actively worried about
that but listen I mean we're going to be
vigilant about any change it would well
what worries me about is like the speed
I think that he actually could do I
really I
don't think that were taken very like it
would be a one day two day event and
like it would be completely shut down
like we wouldn't the habeas corpus is
like he was Obama took that out all you
would have to do is label as terrorists
label congressman terrorists you know
borrow our military's obama obama didn't
suspend habeas corpus did you did you
mean Obama or did you mean Trump well no
I with he essentially repeals a piece
corpus they can all here to do basically
is labels as a terrorist and we could be
jailed in a military prison without a
trial and definitely is this thing you
one thing it like are you ever worried
about Trump or is this just a way to
criticize Obama because what you're
saying is sounding kind of it no I
started up without a film without is
Jones like well what I'm saying is it I
feel like it Obama just didn't but I
don't know it's not a is a conspiracy
thing with it like I don't that's one
saying i'm not on follow i was jonesing
was like this is just something that's
kind of coming up in my mind okay as a
recently you know I'm saying like I now
listen to you God is in secular talk and
cool and stuff like that it's just i see
i see the possibility for rightly like
with the youtube thing how it's kind of
hit everybody like some of the most
prominent people on the left right and
one of their vital point you know what
i'm saying is yes it's not just Trump in
the air is kind of everything come
together yeah and the interest of
seeking consensus I share your concern
about a diversity of voices being
restricted under Trump I think is that
the polite way Pat to say we there's a
grain of agreement here that's a nice
way to end it isn't it yeah thank you so
much now I appreciate you bringing it up
I it's a bit much for me right now to
jump to but it's certainly an issue
we're going to keep an eye on